what we're recording is response
basically to some comments that were
posted on the entropy video and so
youtubers are pretty bad reputation in
terms of the quality of its comments
usually and sometimes you get abusive
comments sometimes you don't get such
intelligent comments but that I really
don't feel that's the case for sixty
symbols in fact we get some quite
perceptive quite intelligent quite
thought-provoking comments both positive
and negative on the videos and in
particular with the entropy video I've
had a number of emails of a number of
comments posted under the video and
there have been a number of really
important questions raised and I guess
the thing that I'm slightly
uncomfortable about with that without
video which I felt I could have put
across a lot better was to really point
out the difference between an analogy
and what's actually going on and so a
coronal rule I used to teach for six
years I taught first year module on
thermal and kinetic physics where
entropy plays a key role and my cardinal
rule was to make that distinction
when I've given that I haven't so bid
that cardinal rule in the video I feel a
little bit uncomfortable and people have
picked up and out and quite rightly
picked up on that so let me stay for
other words well there are a couple of
things they somebody called penguin gin
and somebody called human chemistry 101
have asked questions about well I've
suggested that what I really didn't put
across was the idea of the sort of
evolution or the history of entropy I
guess what I need to point out and it's
stated on that only sixty symbols
website but maybe I need to reiterate
that is that when we do these videos
they're not meant to be tutorials not
really meant to be lectures the men2b
what does that symbol mean to a
particular scientist and if somebody
says entropy to me the first name that
springs into my head is Boltzmann and
the first concept that springs into my
head is the connection of entropy to
configurations and arrangements and
that's what you get the video but of
course having taught the course for
quite some time I am well aware that
there are people like Clausius like
carnal who really made him very
important contributions to entropy but
for me when I hear entropy Boltzmann
springs to mind and that's the first
point so okay I guess I belong
Stover to a certain extent a history the
second point I think perhaps the more
important point is so I talked about in
that video about students and
distributions of students and how
students are moving around and how the
entropy of those students changes
and we could think of for example with
the students here who are milder both of
milling about the filling out this space
quite well we could think about bringing
those into what we term a low entropy
state where we pack them all nicely
together nicely ordered in the center of
this this lovely green and then as they
sort of spread out move away from that
nice orders did we see we're moving to a
higher entropy state and that's really
what entropy is about it's about this
dispersal of energy about this moving
from a state where everything's nicely
packed and they can nicely take the
order into one where evidence spreads
out and you can play that to gas
molecules just as easy to can apply to
students the difficulty is you have to I
what I didn't make a hundred percent
clear and what I spend so much time
doing in my lectures which is why it's
so frustrating is that this isn't it
this is an analogy when I talk about
those students I'm really thinking in my
head of gas molecules moving around and
these concepts of entropy apply to gas
molecules we can't say that a particular
arrangement of students has a
thermodynamic entropy but a particular
arrangement of gas molecules dodds and
the as those gas molecules spread out as
they disperse that that's really the
essence of entropy but for example time
and time again you'll see entropy just
got discussed in terms of well if I have
a nice ordered system or let's let's
let's use some curds if I have some nice
orderly system where these cards are
lined up all the same and all in the
same sort of stead that for example if
as a after some time they do that well
this is an example of entropy is an
example of disorder increasing but that
applies to gas molecules it doesn't
apply to real-world objects like this
there is no difference in the
thermodynamic entropy or entropy of that
particular arrangement compared to that
particular entry arrangement where the
entropy has changed is in terms of when
I do work when I move these around to my
muscles that's where the entropy is and
so having spent so much time during my
undergraduate lectures pouring a product
rose this
this this very important distinction
between an analogy and what's actually
happening I was a little bit Gotthard to
to find that I hadn't really thought
across that that that's a well in the in
the video and entropy and the final
thing I guess is people have picked up
on well you should have covered the the
arrow of time you should have covered
highway into people there's a second to
this law we can't these are five-minute
videos and of 10 minute videos and what
we're trying to do is really as I said
try to put across the essence of what
these things mean to us what brady
particularly with me spends most of his
time doing is editing out I might talk
for an hour and then I put Brady in a
horrible position of well what what do I
use here and so I what I'm delighted to
say is that the entropy video has
generated so much discussion and debate
nuts really what I'm doing this for to
have that debate discussion and to have
people email me I'm delighted about that
but I would have preferred I guess if I
had discussed things and described
things in a slightly different manner so
you really do read all your comments
look absolutely yeah it's it can be
eye-opening and it's just like with
undergraduate lectures you we get
questionnaires and you know those
questionnaires the very vast majority
okay you get some strains and silly
comments like there should be more beer
in lectures but the vast majority of
those are very mature even from
first-year students very mature very
important comments that feedback in and
guide my teaching and I sort of see
these YouTube videos it's a real
learning experience for me
and particularly trained I find it
extremely difficult to compress an hour
down into ten minutes really really
really difficult and
and yeah so those comments are really
useful